[Music]
I still feel bad for her you know I mean
it's hot it's hard
the explosive new Britney drama is the
pop star on crystal meth I decided to
wear a dress to the gym to see what it
feels like don't believe what you read
online 99 of the time those are all
click baits the war of words started
with reports in two British tabloids
both quoting Britney's ex Kevin
Federline I fear she's on meth I've been
praying someone would make it public and
that she wakes up it's terrifying
the reports go on to claim k-fed feared
britwood overdose and that he attempted
an intervention in February one story
also alleged that Britney's son saw
someone bring her what appeared to be
drugs the boys have decided that you
know
they they're they're not seen her right
now there's a lot of things that were
going on that they just didn't feel
comfortable with both articles were
reported by journalist Daphne Brock who
spent 12 days filming with Kevin and his
two sons 17 year old Preston and 16 year
old Jaden Brittany has not seen the boys
in over a year this is our safe place to
you know process all the emotional
trauma that we've been through the drug
allegations brought quick denials I'm
extremely happy I have a beautiful home
beautiful children Brittany who just
celebrated her first wedding anniversary
with her husband Sam isgari fired back
on Instagram quote the fact that people
are claiming things that are not true is
so sad it breaks my heart and the news
is so low I once again want to thank
Brittany Spears for her courage in a
statement to E.T her attorney Matthew
Rosengard called the story's defamatory
and poor and shoddy journalism even
Kevin denied the meth reports calling
them false and repulsive this morning we
reached out to Daphne Barack whose rep
said the journalist absolutely stands by
the story claiming that Kevin expressed
his fears to members of the production
team clearly and repeatedly all this is
Kevin gets ready to pack up the kids and
move to Hawaii Britney signed off on the
request late last month she's not really
exercising any custodial time with
either boys it's not going to deprive
her of any meaningful time with the boys
[Music]